so this might sound weird or silly but
there's this whole section on twitch
where you can watch animals just being
animals
and unfortunately back in september one
of those channels was actually accused
of animal abuse
and the twitch streamer that made the
accusations was then banned for 14 days
due to harassment
but she says the channel she made the
accusations against
is just trying to shut her up and to top
it all off
this specific channel has a history of
animal abuse allegations
it's just the first time we're hearing
about it
all right guys by subscribing to the
channel you're really helping us figure
out what stories you want to see covered
here on don't add me
so if you subscribe to the channel you
leave a comment below or hell you even
send us a tip via email
who knows you might see your story here
so adorable stars
is a cat breeder based out of florida
and they have a twitch channel dedicated
to watching cats
well be cats this isn't unusual on
twitch there's a whole subsection of the
platform dedicated to watching animals
hang out on stream
seriously do you want to watch ducks
rabbits or turtles eat and [ __ ]
everywhere
there's probably a channel for you
now back on september 2nd twitch
streamer alicia accused adorable stars
of essentially running a kitten mill
and a kitten mill is basically a breeder
who neglects the health and safety of
the animal
often breeding solely for profit and
animals that come
from the male system typically have a
lot of health issues and are
malnourished
now after making her initial allegation
alicia and a bunch of people in her
replies
started posting more and more evidence
alleging that adorable stars was in fact
kitten mill from anecdotal yahoo reviews
to a few hard to watch instagram stories
documenting the health problems of a
kitten bought from adorable stars
people were coming out of the woodwork
and not long after alicia made her
allegations she was actually
banned on twitch for 14 days due to
harassment now while her allegations
gained
some traction it was actually destiny
who's a friend of alicia's
commenting on the fact that she got
banned that caused this whole thing to
explode
like we're talking about 57 000 upvotes
on live stream fails
you guys know that stream alicia did a
while ago about those um
about the kitty mill on twitch yeah
apparently their lawyers sent twitch a
letter and got her [ __ ] banned
really holy yeah that's why our stream
is banned right now
and unsurprisingly people were pissed at
both adorable stars for allegedly being
a kitten male
and for twitch for banning alicia due to
harassment okay but why was she banned
for harassment
well in a youtube statement that she
posted alicia says that a specific
company emailed twitch essentially
trying to shut her down
twitch has yet to respond to me on what
my ban was for
they did however share with me that my
ban is for 14 days and that it was for
harassment
no further details i was however emailed
by a specific
business um who boasted to me that they
were in fact the reason
why i was banned and during a twitter
conversation
alicia told me that this same company
emailed her
specifically gloating about the fact
that they were just essentially trying
to shut her down
throughout the rest of the video she
addresses the fact that she's worried
about legal backlash
as well as the numerous stories that
have come from her posting these initial
allegations
but here's where things get wild not
only are there all of these
anecdotal stories about adorable stars
but the woman who allegedly
runs it has a long criminal history
related to the mistreatment of animals
and people were calling attention to
this and the replies to alicia's
original allegations
and because the state of florida is a
wild-ass place that makes arrest records
easily available to the public
i was able to find out exactly what
those charges are in june of 2018 the
person who allegedly runs adorable stars
was charged with forging a veterinary
certificate which
is a felony in the state of florida they
were also charged with forging the
signature of a veterinary doctor which
is also a potential felony in the state
of florida
as well as quote the violation of health
requirements when it comes to the sale
of an animal
adorable stars is also listed on
multiple websites warning customers of
potential scams
and the better business bureau page for
the company has a complaint from the
customer who paid almost two thousand
dollars for her cat
had a vet doctor say that this cat is
not fit for sale
and then the cat died 10 days later and
to cap it all off
adorable stars is under open
investigation from the animal and plant
health inspection services
which is a licensing and regulatory body
in the united states and to be clear
all of this information has been readily
available on the internet for
years yet here they are streaming on
twitch
okay let's just recap this quick a
twitch streamer alleged that a specific
twitch channel dedicated to watching
animals hang out on stream
was essentially running a kitten mill
and they backed this up with evidence
then
that twitch channel which is still live
in streaming accused the streamer of
harassing them
and got her essentially banned off
twitch for 14 days
this company then allegedly emailed the
streamer gloating about the fact that
they got them shut down
and then they've been harassing them on
social media ever since
now according to alicia her ban is up on
friday october 23rd and her first stream
back is going to be raising money for
the humane society
and in talking with me she also said
that she's looking to work with somebody
from the humane society
to further her investigation
what kind of animal would you be keith
if you had to be an animal
what do you think because i know what i
would be i'd be a [ __ ] some form of
bear
some angry [ __ ] bear you know i would
i would be a bear as an animal
and imagine i just have a twitch channel
dedicated to me
being a bear